please forgive me i said i was gonna do
reddit saturday every saturday and i was
wrong and i
scammed a bunch of you into posting
reddit content and then i didn't react
to it so today we're gonna do a special
episode where i give away
all right i'm not gonna sing dude nah it
wasn't that bad of a time you're not
getting that
but basically we're giving doing a
special episode where we react to all
your content from this month
a month of non-reactions gonna give a
bunch you guys gold
because you deserve it uh so let's go to
the board let's do this huh
it's been a minute i'm rusty i don't
know if i have my same chops
dude let's fire up the old reddit has
everyone
abandoned me has it does anybody still
care is anyone still posting is it dead
the thread dead dude i promise
i'll never abandon this page again okay
gonna give a lot of
golds today so get used to it right now
actually i'm gonna give gold before even
look at this
boom oh look at that a free award that i
won
here's the first one dude explaining how
he made 10 million dollars
get up at 5 a.m every day 90 minutes of
cardio take a culture okay this is
familiar
uh journal schedule out your day
dad owns fortune 500 company meditate
i'm sure number six has nothing to do
with it that is how it'd be though
i mean people really are like hey i
started making my bad
and then i became yeah a ceo of a
fabulously
you know uh successful company it's
ridiculous
i'm a diligent dabber here's my stoner
coffeezilla would love to get stephen to
see this
hey i don't do drugs guys i don't
i don't seriously i've literally never
smoked weed in my life
okay okay they all own lamborghinis
right
what fake gurus want you to think their
life is like what their life is actually
like
it's a little bit true though i mean if
you guys knew how many of these guys
thing
everything's just rented so yeah i buy
it i know nothing about the brian rose
uh but the fact his campaign slogan is
slapped across his wife faced
in the family first section of his
campaign website does not make a good
first impression that reminds me
hey play that mike wazowski clip we're
working for a better tomorrow
she's like right here i come i'm uh i'm
on the family first page
uh yeah that that's funny dude that's
really funny
jay mazzini was just the beginning uh
you're right grant that's why i stole
your plane and girl coffeezilla
don't oh i missed i didn't say it in the
right order dude guys you have to bubble
right you can't
bump i read this first don't believe
them when they
say you can't have it all grant cardone
and that's grant cardo
hey that's rude i don't approve of this
message i would never
guys please by the way have you all seen
grant cardone go completely insane
hi interactive boot camp hi hi
hi interactive boot camp guys when you
reach a
certain amount of wealth you get reduced
to guttural noises of a chimp
that's that's what grant has become this
is uh his ad
apparently spend three days with grant
live and achieve major breakthroughs
if you were gonna make a parody of this
what would you even add
you just repost his post
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway so we don't even need this pose
we don't even need the post of
cuck and grant we need the post of just
him advertising himself
by the way also since you were talking
about jay mazzini getting arrested did
any of y'all see him in court crying
dude this is unbelievable he sees it all
finally kick in and he's about to ask
the judge if they can have an earlier
sentencing because he he doesn't want to
be in jail anymore
i'm saying can there can there be an
earlier date
earlier court date no not that i know of
why that's the judge
counsel he's crying dude
listen i know it's kind of heartless to
enjoy this but i have watched this man
steal from
so many people and for those people
this is an incredible sense of
vindication but yeah i thought i'd give
you guys an update with that
who are some actors who can play coffee
still oh by the way we got to give these
people gold
gold for you gold for you and for you
sir and for you def i haven't forgotten
uh and of course
yes for you thank you guys for
participating in our slash
coffeezilla underscore gg even when i
wasn't around even when all hope seemed
lost
who are some actors who can play coffees
like here's one who the hell is this
dude that guy looks
nothing like me i don't see it who's up
for a round of drip bingo next friday
hey what the hell is this have some
respect
okay are you saying we're predictable
absolutely not oh wait that's actually
on the
bingo is plays the exploding bomb sound
by the way guys good time to mention
we changed the new time for the trip to
thursday nights
8 p.m central time starting from now on
it's gonna be a little night rip and dip
okay it's different i'll give that a
gold though
alex becker pivoting to a new industry i
know dude he's gone legit right he's
like trying to be more
about the minimalist thing oh
oh no oh
he's gone the altcoin route i forgot
about that what is he what are you doing
alex you know
exercise is an mlm exercise gives you
energy but you need energy to exercise
sounds like a pyramid scheme uh
yeah guys that's why i don't exercise
brian for mayor
on twitter has a lot of great stuff but
this is a winner for me so far
makes me spit out out my tea every damn
time i see it okay this guy's for sure
from london
i i literally drink
dude he really did that play the clip
dude
and i have a glass of a beverage this is
my own
urine and uh i'm gonna drink it today
with timothy
i think he's tried to scrub it from the
internet but bryant will never forget
your number one baby number one
londonreelscams.org
that is a 10 out of 10 meme someone
needs to tell brian rose how betting
odds work
hi brian rose just a word of caution
about these odds i'm in fourth place
here and i'm not even running
dude i've been telling you guys the odds
mean nothing he keeps talking about it
just because he's a grifter
brian gathers his entire london-based
support for covid's safe photo
opportunity
come on dude that's dude brian's kind of
tiny there to be honest
i speaking as you know someone familiar
with the shire
i gotta say brian is gonna fit right in
interesting question
if they're already earning in dollars
why the hell
are they teaching it for dollars
uh you know why because they're not
actually
earning that dude here's one of these
types he says 400k
drop shipping revenue 15 years old
he calls himself the ceo of teenage
money and he wants he already has a
thousand students guys he's 15
but he has a thousand students this is
the epitome of that meme
and these people's instagram is just
like this hallel it's unironically
hilarious
takes risks to get here hard work pays
off
hey buddy you're not even out of your
teenage
years yet but go back into high school
you're truant i could probably call the
cops on you
for being truant from high school go
back to class go back to science class
and stop pretending that you're some big
shot entrepreneur with a thousand
students
all right we're gonna end it on this
inspirational and real quotes
from mr testosterone filled left
testicle himself
okay that's oddly specific oh it's this
guy
the last thing i told my mom was you're
not
effing sick you're not gonna die
stop being a what
real quote get some help dan pina dude
stop trying to run like 12 businesses
you need like 12 appointments bud with
various psychologists and therapists
i don't know what to tell you anyway
that's basically it uh
just went over some of these memes i
hope you enjoyed it i'll give this guy
gold why not
i'm being very generous and to anyone
who comes to the subreddit i'm gonna be
generously giving gold over the next
week
to stimulate the economy guys that's
right i'm pumping
my own subreddit and for this next week
i want you to focus
on deep diving grant cardone's instagram
show me what i know this guy's been
posting some crazy stuff i haven't had
time to track at all
dig it up let's find out what's really
in grant cardone's instagram and for
that matter in the ceo
instagram dude i know these people are
insane let's find out what's really
going on
anyway we'll be reviewing that next week
guys net reddit saturday is now a
regular thing again i promise i will
never scam you again thank you for
watching thank you for supporting
pop the stock and i'll see you guys next
time
wake up and smell the coffee